public sénat en partenariat avec life
fait les échos aura du classique
présente l'épreuve de vérité
[Musique]
stéphane travert le ministre de
l'agriculture est notre invité ici au
salon de l'agriculture monsieur le
ministre
bonsoir bonsoir et merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation de public sénat avec
les échos radio classique et l' agence
france-presse
vous êtes ici toute la semaine est ce
que vous cherchez à battre un record
olympique comme le président de la
république vous aussi on n'est pas là
pour battre des records non on est là
pour rencontrer les gens entendre
travailler et c'est important d'être ici
dès l'aube jusqu'à la nuit tombée dès
l'aube jusqu'à tomber je suis un des
derniers à repartir mais c'est important
d'être ici par son actualité agricole
elle est là c'est le salon de
l'agriculture est mise à la culture et
de l'alimentation
celle à qui doit elle est celle ci les
crises avec des nuages noirs
on va vous en parler on va beaucoup vous
interroger au cours de cette émission
avec mes amis qui sont présents ici
lucile bréau et jérémy marot il y aura
donc trois grandes questions dans votre
secteur monsieur le ministre
1 quel modèle agricole finalement à
votre faveur on aimerait comprendre
d'eux la fin des promos annoncé avec
votre loi est ce un marché de dupes les
consommateurs quand ils paient plus cher
et est ce qu'on est sûr que les
producteurs pourront être eu des
gagnants cette affaire troisième
question l'europe est elle toujours
l'allié des agriculteurs mais d'abord
une toute question une toute première
question d'actualité puisque le
gouvernement a présenté la réforme la
révolution de la sncf il ya un point sur
lequel le gouvernement ne suit pas le
rapport spinetta c'est sur les petites
lignes
elles sont maintenues janvier dire elles
sont sauvées est ce que vous êtes vous
ce soir soulagé moi vous savez je suis
très attaché aux services publics les
premier ministre l'a dit aujourd'hui ils
ne prendraient pas tous du rapport
spinetta
d'abord il va sauver et maintenir les
petites lignes pourquoi soulagé heureux
ce soir mais bien sûr parce qu'il s'agit
des transports du quotidien et ses
transports du quotidien ce sont ces
problématiques que les français sur
lesquels ils nous ont appelés depuis un
certain nombre de mois pour ré
les des situations qui aujourd'hui
accueille ne conviennent plus le service
public n'est pas suffisamment rendu et
le premier ministre a dit qu il était
hors de question de remettre en cause la
notion de service public autour de la
sncf
et bien évidemment nous allons
travailler dans ce sens et jérémy il ya
tout de même un point qui suscite les
interrogations c'est celui du recours
aux ordonnances
est ce que vous ne craignez pas que ça
met tout simplement le feu aux poudres
mais il s'agit d' ordonnance qui seront
rendus sur des points techniques et donc
nous sommes sur ce point technique il va
falloir passer par ordonnance pour
pouvoir accélérer
parce que vous souvenez que le premier
ministre a bien dit que la situation de
la sncf était dans une situation telle
qu'il fallait agir vite et à partir du
moment où sur les points techniques on
agit par ordonnance mais que dans le
même temps on laisse la place à la
concertation
on laisse la place à la négociation avec
l'ensemble des cheminots
aujourd'hui je ne vois pas en quoi cela
pose problème il faut avancer faire en
sorte que ce service a dû prendre la
pose pas dire monsieur le ministre on
parle effectivement de points techniques
comme vous dites concrètement on parle
de quoi en fait c'est comment
aujourd'hui nous portons un intérêt
particulier sur ces transports du
quotidien comment nous adaptons l'offre
ferroviaire à l'exigence des clients car
à l'exil en vous nous avez été
parlementaire les parlementaires
considèrent que c'est un déni de
démocratie
je ne sais pas interroger interrogé
l'ensemble des parlementaires je n'ai
pas vu sur les réseaux sociaux ou
ailleurs des levées de boucliers de
parlementaires s'agiter sur le recours
aux ordonnances va y aller quand josé
n'a par exemple gérard larcher qui lui
c'est un déni de débat en ouvrant le
débat par le filet
président larcher mais les ordonnances
permettent la concertation nous allons
d'ailleurs les utiliser dans la loi sur
l'agriculture
nous y reviendrons tout à l'heure je
rêverais que sur ces points techniques
c'est important mais la négociation et
la concertation
elle doit avoir lieu à corps avec les
cheminots mais il ne peut y avoir de
blocage sur la nécessité de transformer
aujourd'hui la sncf de demain pour que
le service public soit rendue et bien
rendu pas de blocage mais justement
c'est la question du style
voilà où est ce qu'on met la borne de
l'utilisation de ces ordonnances parce
qu'au bout d'un moment on se dit est ce
que on prend pas le risque à terme de
voir la france bloquée on voit des
cheminots très remonté très mobilisés
qui s'inquiètent pour leur statut dix
statues qui a priori a vocation à
disparaître le premier ministre l'a dit
est ce que dans quelques mois la france
ne risque pas d'être bloqués comme sur
la question d'où viens tu le premier
ministre a bien déclaré qu' il y aurait
une discussion et une négociation sur la
région le danger 9h 10h la mise en
oeuvre mais il faut laisser la
concertation se faire on ne peut pas
bloquer les choses avant même d'avoir
commencé à discuter et moi bien
évidemment j'appelle à ce que cette
concertation ait lieu
aujourd'hui il ya une défaillance dans
le service public rendu par la sncf
il faut réparer tout cela et faire en
sorte que demain la sncf puisse proposer
le meilleur service public à l'ensemble
de nos concitoyens et notamment des
concitoyens qui ont besoin des trains du
quotidien et bien souvent ce sont les
concitoyens les plus pauvres les plus
démunis qui utilise le train et moi
c'est quelque chose qui est important à
mes yeux très bien nous allons aborder
maintenant les dossiers agricoles avec
la première question de cette émission
que vous pose de lucile bréau alors la
première question à l'est
a man
lucile votre question est si hardy pour
la présence yardi pour la présenter au
salon de l'agriculture parce que c'est
évidemment une question d'actualité liés
à ce salon de l'agriculture on n'a pas
très bien compris au final quel modèle
agricole vous défendez vous et le
président de la république à travers
vous qui quels modèles agricoles à votre
faveur vous appelez de vos voeux pour
l'avenir
mais comme le président de la république
nous ne voulons pas nous enfermer dans
un modèle agricole la france sa richesse
sa diversité
c'est d'avoir plusieurs modèles
agricoles les modèles agricoles basé sur
des circuits courts des ateliers de
transformation dans la proximité
mais une agriculture qui produit plus
une droiture ristourner liste le man
booker une agriculture tourner vers les
croiseurs civis tournées vers l'export
est tourné vers la qualité une
agriculture tourner vers le bio une
agriculture tourner vers les signes de
qualité et c'est autour de ces modèles
agricoles que nous souhaitons créer à la
fois avec leur diversité crée de la
valeur crée de la richesse créée de la
fois vous ne voulez pas de choisir mais
ce n'est pas une question de choisir
aujourd'hui il ne s'agit pas d'en mener
notre pays sur un seul et unique modèle
qui laisserait des perdants sur le bord
de la route
aujourd'hui nous avons besoin de la
diversité des radios comme perdants car
je vois que depuis très peu de temps
maintenant
il y a un déficit commercial un des
produits agricoles via nissan versa le
cas il ya quelques années et on voit des
pays qui triomphe alors avec d'autres
méthodes
je pense à l'allemagne aux pays bas avec
des fermes usines qui ne sont pas
effectivement notre modèle mais qui
semble vous voyez des points sur le
paris vous voyez vous nous rejoignez là
dessus oui le modèle allemand n'est pas
le modèle français aujourd'hui les
français interrogés les ici sur ce salon
ils vous diront que le modèle qu'ils
souhaitent c'est une ferme qui soit une
ferme qui maillent le territoire
généralement ce sont des fermes des
associations autour de gamme est qu'au
cours de autour de sarl exploitations
familiales ou exploitation autour de
quatre ou cinq associés ce sont des
fermes à taille humaine sur lesquelles
nous avons la capacité de produire à la
fois de la qualité à la fois de porter
une exigence particulière sur les
exportations parce que nous avons
loin de la qualité de nos produits
agricoles ils font l'honneur de la
france
mais il peut le faire aussi la richesse
de notre balance commerciale et nous y
travaillons
c'est ce que nous avons fait en
réouvrant les marchés chinois en
réouvrant le marché turc en réouvrant le
marché vietnamien sur la pomme de terre
en réouvrant le marché japonais sur le
foie gras
voilà ce qui fait là beaucoup d'eau et
de la mort g ctif de rétablir la balance
commerciale justement des produits
agricoles est ce que c'est un des
objectifs du quinquennat bien sûr que
cédric objectif de rétablir à haga léger
ans mais aujourd'hui c'est une échéance
l'échéance c'est le quinquennat bien
évidemment et c'est de travailler à
rétablir là le déclic c'est plus de 180
millions d'euros bien sûr mais nous
partons de loin mais nous avons besoin
de miser à la fois sur la qualité sur la
diversité de nos modèles de production
et de travailler avec les agriculteurs
pour transformer notre agriculture à
travers la formation à travers
l'innovation mais aussi à travers la
compétitivité dont nous avons besoin
gérer mes qualités sont aussi miser sur
le bio ya plan bio qui a été confirmé
par wendel m'accrocher des derniers 15
pensant objectif 15 % des surfaces
agricoles en bio alors maintenant parlez
nous du financement
nicolas hulot dimanche dans le journal
du dimanche a parlé également de la
création d'un fonds pour les
agriculteurs bio en difficulté comment
tout cela est il financé
alors aujourd'hui sur cette question du
bio nous avons effectivement porter une
ambition forte
il y à une demande très forte de la
population de nos concitoyens vers les
produits vers les produits bio
aujourd'hui nous ne devons diminuer les
importations de produits bio parce que
importer des tomates qui qui viennent
d'ailleurs en bio c'est un non sens
écologique et environnementale et donc
nous avons besoin de structurer l'offre
augmenté l'offre de produits de produits
bio donc nous avons besoin d'accompagner
des agriculteurs dans la conversion pour
répondre justement à notre objectif de
15 % de la surface agricole utile
doubler la surface du studio on est on
est à six et demi aujourd'hui sage il
veut que nous d'aller la question des
boules et je suis en ce moment il y a
effectivement moi j'avais déjà proposé
il y a quelques mois la création d'un
fonds privés autour de la bio pour
financer avec des opérateurs
ça peut être la grande la grande
distribution par exemple
un certain nombre d'opérateurs autour de
la bio pour financer le développement de
circuits comme cela cela passera aussi
par les aides du feader qui sont
présentes aussi et là c'est une action
que nous devons mener en commun avec les
régions l'état va prendre ses
dispositions et ses responsabilités à
travers les aides à la conversion
nous avons besoin d'amener les
agriculteurs à se convertir à leurs bios
pour celles et ceux qui le souhaitent et
donc voilà le cheminement nous aurons
l'occasion dans quelques semaines de
présenter définitivement le plan bio
nous avons quelques arbitrages encore à
apporter et nous auront tout le loisir
de présenter ce plan ambitieux pour la
france il y aura plusieurs
interpellations pour vous au cours de
cette émission pas seulement celle de
mes confrères et consoeurs ici présents
mais
deux personnes qui par exemple concours
là au bio temps de repos et c'est cet
apiculteur par exemple du morvan qu'a
rencontré quentin calmer et eloïse
grégoire et qui s'adresse directement à
vous monsieur le ministre et lui
eh bien il a une revendication très
précise alors monsieur le ministre
bonjour oui j'aurais une question à vous
poser c'est que
par rapport au bio valeurs nous on est
en bien on est des vieux du bio 1 ça
fait 30 ans qu'on est là dedans pour n'a
pas de hyères 1 côtoient des centaines
d'agriculteurs conventionnelles tout
sympa et on sent bien une évolution chez
eux ici réfléchissent ils ont concerné
qui a un problème
et moi je pense je pense sincèrement que
l'avenir ne peut venir que si la
formation suit ça veut dire dans les
lycées dans les collèges
ça veut dire au moins est sensibilisé
parce qu'ils sont prêts ils demandent
ils ont qui je pense que c'est la clé
c'est la clé du problème et j'espère de
tout coeur que vous irez dans ce sens je
pense que cet apiculteur sur un
formidable pédagogue et qu'est ce que
vous lui répondez à mais moi je réponds
qu'il a totalement raison moi je suis
d'accord avec lui à cent pour cent
aujourd'hui il y à une demande pour la
conversion en bio il ya une demande de
nos consoles de nos consommateurs et de
nos concitoyens mais nous devons faire
en sorte que le bio soit a pris dans les
lycées agricoles
lorsque j'ai présenté le budget pour
l'agriculture dans le programme projet
de loi de finances 2010 8 j'avais mis
trois priorités la formation et
l'éducation
le sanitaire et la pac et sur les
formations
nous devons mettre un accent particulier
à l'intérieur des lycées agricoles dans
les programmes sur la formation à la
culture de l'agriculture biologique et
je crois que là aussi nous devons faire
cet effort et nous allons y contribuer
parce que dès lors nous avons avoir
besoin d'agriculteurs supplémentaires
sur le bio il va falloir les former à
ces techniques parce que vous le savez
le bio c'est un cahier des charges qui
est très très important c'est un travail
plus très difficile pour tenir
je dirais l'ensemble de la
réglementation pour pouvoir produire bio
ça travaille dur et donc nous devons
accompagner les jeunes pour le faire et
moi j'ai été président d'un lycée
agricole pendant cinq ans et je peux
vous dire qu'après la conversion en bio
nous avions besoin aussi de former les
enseignants de former
les élèves et les apprenants qui étaient
ici pour pouvoir mieux démarrer ensuite
leur exploitation lucile vous donner la
priorité à la conversion on vous a
entendu il ya déjà des agriculteurs qui
ont fait cet effort de se convertir et
aujourd'hui ils sont plombées parce que
ils ne reçoivent pas les aides qu'ils
devraient recevoir
il ya des retards de paiement est ce que
vous pouvez aujourd'hui vous engagez ici
au salon et leur dire vous êtes
désormais seront versés en oeuvre et en
temps mais madame réaux vous le savez on
en a déjà parlé
les aides lorsque je suis arrivé au
ministère nous avons publié un
calendrier des paiements des aides mike
2015 ont été payés en novembre elles ont
elles ont été payées en novembre les
aides 2016 seront payés pour le mois
d'avril
elles seront payées pour le mois d'avril
vers la fin du mois d'avril les aides
2017 seront payés en octobre ou novembre
dans cette dans cette période à ce qui
fait que dès cette année 2018
nous aurons retrouvé un calendrier
vertueux de versement des aides alors
sur les aides 2015 nous avons payé 90 %
des aides
il reste 10 % des dossiers où il ya un
certain nombre de difficultés
soit un manque d'information des
problèmes de signatures sur lesquels
nous devons traiter des dossiers un par
un ils restent des signatures mais il y
à 90% des dossiers qui ont été payées si
si c'est vrai et sur les aides 2016
elles seront payées au printemps et les
aides 2017
à la fin de l'année il ya encore des
attentes on les entend juste
10 % où nous avons pour le 2015
rencontré un certain nombre de défis que
l'on est prêt à examiner ces dossiers il
n'y a aucun problème là dessus alors
voilà on les entend dans le public à
l'heure du bio aux produits
phytosanitaires il n'y a qu'un pas n'est
ce pas jérémy exactement sur les
produits phytosanitaires la fnsea
aujourd'hui s'est engagé à trouver des
solutions d'avenir
quelle est votre position sur ces 250
solution d'avenir proposé par la fse
fnsea bardot et ses partenaires mais moi
je considère que la fnsea a fait un très
gros travail
il est important il s'engage aussi dans
la réduction des produits phyto
phytosanitaires et moi je pense que la
fnsea fait ce travail en corrélation et
en coordination avec ce que nous portons
d'accord je trouve que c'est une
excellente nouvelle parce qu'il ya la
raison pouvoir travailler ensemble
est-ce qu'elle a raison la fnsea quand
elle dit ce matin on ne peut pas aller
vers zéro produit phytosanitaire c'est
comme ce serait comme dire et il
faudrait maintenant +0 médicaments pour
les humains mais nous avons nous donner
ce que c'est vous partagez cette idée
nous avons travaillé moi je dit depuis
le début que nous devons travailler sur
les trajectoires
oui c'est la trajectoire qui compte
c'est comment nous pouvons travailler à
faire en sorte de réduire et d'ailleurs
il ya beaucoup d'agriculteurs qui se
sont déjà investi là-dedans et qui ont
beaucoup réduit notamment la question
des antibiotiques
la question des produits phytosanitaires
qui ont été réduits de manière drastique
dans un certain nombre d'élevages et
danser un certain nombre de deux
cultures et donc nous devons continuer à
les accompagner à travailler avec eux
pour pour aller aux épreuves à manger
des légumes on nous a dit récemment
qu'il y avait encore une présence des
pesticides mais massive et bien sûr il
ya encore des choses qui sont utilisés
aujourd'hui
ce que je veux dire c'est que nous
devons travailler sur la trajectoire
la temporalité parce que c'est important
élevé dans la république a eu l'occasion
va falloir attendre quoi c'est le
président de la république a eu
l'occasion de le dire et de le rappeler
pas d'interdiction sans substitution
dites moi on parle de bio là mais je
vois également que le ministre de la
transition écologique en parle beaucoup
mais pas ici puisqu'il n'a décidé de ne
pas venir monsieur
mais qui qui porte ce projet c'est vous
c'est lui vous marcher d'un même pas là
mais vous est-ce que vous avez la même
temporalité que le ministre de la
transition écologique qui dit en
substance
moi c'est moi j'ai la vision à long
terme le ministre lui c'est les crises
d'urgence qu'est ce que vous répondez à
ça et vous savez là dessus je crois
qu'il faut être clair c'est fini le
temps où les ministères travailler en
silo chacun dans son coin sans se
préoccuper de ce qui se passe ailleurs
aujourd'hui il ya un travail en commun
et c'est dommage que vous aussi pourquoi
vous n'êtes pas ensemble écoutez moi je
moi je suis là écoutez moi je suis là et
moi je fais mon boulot en étant là parce
que je suis une mise de la culture et
que ma présence c'est le travail qui est
le mien c'est d'être ici pendant huit
jours après mes collègues ils font ce
qu'ils veulent
moi j'ai grand plaisir à les accueillir
demain j'accueille le premier ministre
j'accueille le ministre de l'éducation
nationale avec qui nous faisons beaucoup
de travaux interrogé mois sur avec le
ministre de l'éducation nationale
interrogé moins sur ce que nous allons
faire avec la mise d outre-mer
interrogés - sur ce que nous allons
faire avec la ministre de l'enseignement
d'autres sujets tout ça parce que
tellement faire les choses maintenant
mes collègues sont libres de faire ce
qu'ils veulent ce n'est pas moi qui gère
l'emploi du temps et les agendas droit
jallet champ libre en fête vous avez des
gens libres si le salon de l'agriculture
s'est ouvert sur le monde
c'est ouvert à tout le monde et moi je
suis très heureux d'accueillir tous les
gens qui viennent ici très bien y
compris nicolas hulot s'il finissait par
se décider en entamant un sondage
opinionway pour cette émission comme
chaque semaine monsieur le ministre et
la première question portait justement
sur la confiance 1 dans la dans la
sécurité alimentaire et les français
se prononce à 70%
oui nous avons confiance c'est un
encouragement
oui c'est un bel encouragement mais
pourquoi parce que depuis quelques
années nous avons fait en sorte que la
sécurité alimentaire soit au rendez vous
c'est une priorité parce que nous devons
cette sécurité alimentaire à nos
concitoyens mais aussi parce que c'est
dû au travail des agriculteurs
alors les agriculteurs ce sont les
premiers acteurs de la sécu pas
confiance c'est quand même 28 % des
français lv1 toujours du travail mais
nous devons convaincre et nous le
faisons nous mêmes au ministère de
l'agriculture en mettant des moyens sur
tout ce qui concerne la sécurité mais
aussi avec le travail des agriculteurs
lui c'est sûr le glyphosate nicolas
hulot en parlait hier dans le jdd en
disant bon voilà on a compris la
trajectoire du gouvernement malgré tout
il pourrait y avoir des exceptions même
si à terme l'objectif visé c'est
l'interdiction est ce que vous pouvez
nous préciser le cadre de ces exceptions
est ce qu'on connaît déjà un petit peu
les grandes lignes vous savez que nous
avons mis en place à une concertation
sur la diminution enfin le travail sur
les produits phyto sanitaires et donc
cette concertation nous aurons nous en
aurons les résultats dans quelques dans
quelques semaines mais ce que je veux
vous dire que le président de la
république là dessus il a été clair pas
d'interdiction sans substitution donc il
nous faut trouver avec avec l'inra avec
les instituts techniques avec l'ensemble
de la recherche et de l'innovation fait
en sorte que nous puissions dans le
délai de trois ans trouver un maximum de
solutions et là où nous n'aurons pas de
solution eh bien il faudra continuer il
ne faudra pas baisser les bras il faudra
continuer continuer à travailler à
mobiliser la recherche pour faire en
sorte de filles au final neuf étrangers
au final des excès
on sait moins incitative qu'une
interdiction à terme oui mais nous ne
sommes pas dans une société n'interdit
nous devons travailler à trouver ces
modifications à trouver les
substitutions et donc nous avons un
calendrier sur le glyphosate c'est clair
ces cinq ans la durée qui a été donné
par laquelle l'union européenne la
france elle veut être devant
elle veut donner l'exemple et elle a
pris 3 en trois ans et la durée sur
laquelle nous allons essayer de
travailler ensuite nous verrons sur
certaines applications
peut-être que cela sera plus long le
président de la république n'a pas dit
autre chose et moi je ne dit pas autre
chose depuis la can alors bien c'est
vrai on a envie vous prend pas en défaut
un monsieur le ministre vous ne dites
pas autre chose que le président de la
république 2e deuxième question de
l'épreuve de vérité tout de suite
[Musique]
deuxième question avec vos jérémy le
gouvernement a annoncé la fin de ses
promotions folle dans les supermarchés
qui ont tant fait parler ces dernières
semaines mais est ce qu'on n'est pas
après tout dans un jeu de dupes où tout
le monde serait perdant les producteurs
comme les consommateurs mais non parce
que le sens de travail les états
généraux c'est quoi c'est réussir à
faire des contrats gagnant gagnant
gagnant
qu'est ce que c'est que le juste prix le
juste prix c'est celui qui rémunère tous
les acteurs de la chaîne
le producteur qui ne l'étaient pas le
transformateur est aussi le distributeur
d'ailleurs je voudrais vous dire on ne
supprime pas toutes les promotions nous
supprimons un type de promotion nous
encadrons les promotions jusqu'à 34 %
c'est-à-dire que le a acheté un gratuit
qui détruit de la valeur qui empêche de
redistribuer cette valeur aux
agriculteurs là nous allons partir sur
une expérimentation de deux ans c'est
prévu dans le projet de loi que nous
aurons à défendre à partir du fait de la
fin du mois de mars début du mois
d'avril
et comment est-ce qu'on peut être
certain à terme que c'est bien le
producteur qui bénéficiera de ces
mesures c'est tout simplement tout
simplement l'homme bréau par le contrat
parce que nous allons faire en sorte à
travers la loi que les agriculteurs
puissent sur des bassins sur des bassins
de production se constituer en
organisation de producteurs
ces six organisations de producteurs
elles auront des pouvoirs qui seront
renforcées de manière à ce qu'elles
puissent contractualiser faire un
contrat avec un transformateur une
laiterie par exemple ou un distributeur
pour livrer des fruits et des légumes et
sur cette notion de contrat avec des
indicateurs de prix qui seront
travaillées à partir des filières des
chiffres des filières est confirmée et
est talonné par l'observatoire des prix
et des marges
parce que vous savez bien que si on
prend un exemple pourrait collecter un
litre de lait en montagne
coûte beaucoup plus cher aujourd'hui que
de le connecter dans ma région dans la
plaine normande et donc nous avons
besoin d'avoir des coûts de production
qui soit adapté bien évidemment à chaque
bassin de production et de fait les
producteurs ne pourront plus vendre
grâce à cela en dessous de leur prix de
revient et vous demandez vous allez
demander aux consommateurs de payer plus
cher les produits agricoles
alors vous avez vu qu'aujourd'hui je ne
me trompe pas et alors quel pourcentage
quel est le pourcentage de cette
inflation que vous allez déclenché mais
monsieur grossiord vous connaissez
parfaitement les sujets économiques et
vous savez bien que nous ne sommes pas
dans une économie administrée à wigan
fixe et moi je lis je lis les l'ufc que
je suis moi je défends les consommateurs
et qui dit ça va flamber de 10 % oui
mais qu'est ce que dit le l'ufc que
choisir il se trompe parce quand même la
méthodologie et de lui et de son bien
alors mais la méthodologie du ufc que
choisir ces deux d'augmenter de 10%
l'ensemble des prix même les prix des
produits non alimentaires et de l'est de
les mettre sur deux ans alors que nous
nous portons une exigence d'abord sur
les produits agricoles
c'est ce que l'on va faire autour du
seuil de revente à perte pour lisser les
marges sur l'ensemble des produits
prenons un exemple concret qui est
illustre parfaitement ce que nous
voulons faire aujourd'hui les la
distribution vent de la pâte à tartiner
à des prix totalement cassée et pour se
refaire ils vont faire des marges sur
des produits agricoles qu'ils auront
acheté à des très bas prix aux
agriculteurs nous ce que nous voulons
faire c'est remettre de la marge sur les
produits comme la pâte à tartiner
remettre de la marge sur l'ensemble des
produits de manière à lisser le prix
bien et en plus vous avez vu il ce matin
dans l'actualité que un certain nombre
de consommateurs sont prêts aujourd'hui
sur un certain nombre de produits et de
production à payer plus cher dès lors où
il s'agit de productions locales
dès lors où il s'agit de production
biologique dès lors où la qualité est au
rendez vous je vous confirme tout ça
avec la deuxième question de notre
sondage opinionway est-ce que vous êtes
prêts à augmenter la part de votre
budget consacré à l'alimentation on sait
que la part du budget consacré à
l'alimentation régresse depuis quelques
années eh bien les français sont prêts à
payer plus à 77% attention à pas
forcément dans des proportions folles au
voulez vous n'avez pas dit un quel était
le pourcentage de hausse que aussi
bizarre ce n'est pas moi qui fixe les
aurais je veux nous ne sommes pas elle
possède que vous pourriez nous parler
d'une hausse tolérable selon vo mais il
y a des indicateurs de près ces
indicateurs de prix ils tiendront compte
des coûts de production et c'est en
fonction des coûts de production que
seront bâtis l'ensemble des prix qui
alerteront dents sur les marchés il n'y
a pas que les producteurs les éleveurs
les agriculteurs qui sont engagés depuis
des années dans un bras de fer avec les
distributeurs j'ai envie de dire
monsieur travers bab vous au 6 mai mais
j'ai trouvé plus royaliste le roi que
laura chez les distributeurs
c'est le directeur des achats de lidl
michel gayraud qui lui écoute est bien
veut supprimer toutes les promotions des
rayons
il ya un projet de loi qui a été
présenté le 31 janvier une fois de plus
je trouve ça vraiment vraiment
formidable mais je pense que ce n'est on
est pas assez à aller assez loin dans ce
projet de loi quand on parle des
limitations des promotions à 34%
c'est bien c'est bien pour des produits
comme le nutella comme le coca pourquoi
pas comme ça les concurrents ils ne
feront plus la guerre mais c'est pas
suffisant pour les produits issus du
monde agricole issus de l'élevage
pourquoi parce que les grandes marques
nationales comme candia et là qu'elles
continueront à faire des promos un pack
acheté le deuxième à moins 60 ce qui
fait toujours que 30 % de réduction
donc ils sont dans le cadre de la loi et
ça ne suffit pas moi je propose
d'interdire tout bonnement les
promotions sur les produits agricoles
sur les produits d'élevage est même allé
plus loin interdire les prix abusivement
bas alors c'est vous qui l'avez retourné
là à écouter on a bien travaillé avec
michel birault il est très présent ici
au salon de l'agriculture ils font des
choses aujourd'hui
lidl a totalement transformé son modèle
économique il faut le dire ils
travaillent ils contractualise avec des
agriculteurs mais moi ce que je dis ici
aujourd'hui par rapport à sa proposition
nous le travail du gouvernement c'est
d'offrir un cadre nous nous souhaitons
encadrer les promotions à 34%
très bien mais personne n'interdit la
marque nos grands distributeurs qui qui
vient de s'exprimer lidl tous les cas de
faire plus avec personne ne l'interdît
et s'ils veulent le faire mais moi je
dis chiche
et d'abord voyons en somme mais voyons
ensuite quels résultats cela donnera
pour ramener de l'argent dans les cours
de ferme et voilà que c'est ça qui
m'intéresse car il ya bien pas que
monsieur lidl il ya monsieur et chez
leclerc aussi à ça se passe pas de la
même manière c'est différent je suis pas
sûr qu'ils soient d'accord jusqu'à
d'accord j'espère monsieur mini s'il ya
des négos en attendant votre loi en
septembre il ya des négociations qui
sont en cours sur les prix actuellement
entre
les producteurs et les distributeurs et
sap a l'air de se passer très très bien
est ce que vous pensez qu'on arrivera à
une relation normalisée entre
producteurs et distributeurs et que
pouvez vous faire pour fluidifier cette
relation alors nous avons fait signer
une charte vous souvenez le 14 novembre
dernier une charte a été signé une
charte d'engagement sur des achats
éthique et responsable entre les
producteurs les distributeurs et les
transformateurs
mais cette charte elle doit être
respectée nous avons réuni à plusieurs
reprises
l'ensemble de nos des acteurs pour leur
rappeler la signification de leur
engagement leur rappeler les obligations
parce que quand on signe un document on
s'engage et ses engagements ils doivent
être tenus
donc nous avons accentué les contrôles
c'est plus de 500 contrôles
supplémentaires par la dgccrf qui ont
été faits et toutes les je dirais toutes
les pratiques illégales où toutes les
pratiques qui allait contre la signature
de la charte seront sanctionnés ou alors
nous utiliserons ce que l'on appelle le
name and shame
nous dirons qui n'a pas joué le jeu qui
n'a pas respecté sa signature qui n'a
pas respecté sa parole ou alors nous
utiliserons le name and shame
c'est à dire que nous diront qu'ils ont
été les plus vertueux dans le travail
très bien alors on attend ça alors une
question encore sur cette thématique là
l'uci va sur cette thématique est ce qui
serait pas plus simple dans votre projet
doit de mettre des mesures vraiment
contraignante l'ufc que choisir disait
aussi à un moment où ça ne passera pas
s'il n'y a pas des mesures vraiment
contraignante dans ce texte vise à vider
des distributeurs plutôt que de parier
nouvelle fois sur le name and shame
est ce qu'il faut pas des amendes m à
l'amande ce qui potentiellement 2
je serai pas le jeu mais il y à un
renforcement du pouvoir de sanction qui
peut être peut être me il y aura le
débat parlementaire nous verrons comment
les choses peuvent se mettre peuvent se
mettre en place mais moi je souhaite
toujours faire place aussi et c'est un
peu la marque de ce2 du ministère que je
porte aujourd'hui c'est l'écoutent
la concertation est ensuite la décision
est donc il faut que nous continuions à
voir cette cette relation un peu
singulière nous avons rendez vous compte
en six mois réussi à remettre tout le
monde autour de la table les gens ne se
parlaient plus et nous avons réussi en
six mois à faire des états généraux
affaires se réunir les transformateurs
les distributeurs et les producteurs à
créer un projet de loi à faire des plans
de filières et donc nous devons
continuer je dirais dans cet esprit de
communication plutôt positive et nous
avons besoin de sa troisième partie de
l'émission monsieur le ministre de
l'agriculture avec la troisième question
tout de suite
en direct
l'europe est elle toujours l'allié des
agriculteurs français aujourd'hui les
subissent
oui l'europe doit être un allié sûr
efforts pour l'agriculture et c'est pour
ça qu'aujourd'hui la france elle a
repris une place forte en europe vous
l'avez vu le président de la république
depuis le début de son mandat a imposé
un chemin sur l'europe
il illustre aujourd'hui cette volonté
européenne d'aller de l'avant et
d'accompagner notre agriculture et nos
agriculteurs et c'est pourquoi nous
défendons une pac qui soit ambitieuse et
nous le savons ce n'est pas simple parce
que il y à un certain nombre de pays il
y à des adversaires de la pac des gens
qui considèrent qu'avec l'argent de la
pac
on peut aller traiter des politiques
d'autres politiques politique migratoire
politique de défense avec le président
de la république et le premier ministre
nous souhaitons porter une pac qui soit
offensive
c'est à dire une pac qui protège nos
agriculteurs une pac qui protège les
agriculteurs contre les aléas
climatiques contre les accidents
sanitaires mais aussi une pac qui puisse
permettre de créer une réserve de
précaution
lorsqu il y a deux des grandes crises
très grande crise parce que aujourd'hui
cette réserve de précaution elle existe
mais nous avons une difficulté c'est que
nous ne pouvons pas la mobiliser
toujours quand nous en avons besoin
il faut un accord quasi unanime pour la
mobiliser et qu'elle n'est pas
mobilisables je dirai au moment venu où
surviennent les crises et donc nous
avons besoin de simplifier le
fonctionnement de la pac pour une europe
qui protège c'est l'europe qui protège
c'est le leitmotiv que disait le
leitmotiv
mais pourtant on entend dans le même
temps le président de la république dire
que la france à l'europe a péché par
naïveté mais c'est un peu l'impression
qu'elle donne aujourd'hui avec ce qu'on
annonce sur les importations d'amérique
latine de viande bovine et c'est halal
en baisse des frontières on baisse les
garanties sanitaires et c'est cette
impression là que les gens et c'est un
des motifs de la révolte aujourd'hui
dans les campagnes justement et la
france elle se défend contre ça parce
que la france pour nous il
hors de question que on aille en deçà
des standards sanitaires que nous
souhaitons imposé et moi j'entends les
craintes des éleveurs sur les différents
traités et les accords commerciaux
j'entends les craintes qui ont été
exprimées ici pendant le salon nous
avons des standards sanitaire des
standards de qualité pont sur lesquels
nous ne souhaitons pas descendre mais en
attendant on va on va signer des accords
avec des pays qui n'est rien ne rend pas
les m'abordent arquin d'abord ces
accords ne sont pas encore signés d'une
part d'autre part on n'a pas entendu que
ces accords soient signés pour qu'il y
ait de l'importation massive déjà de
viande sur notre territoire mais
pourquoi parce que les contrôles au
niveau européen sont insuffisants parce
que les contrôles sont mal faits et donc
nous devons résoudre cette problématique
et avoir de la cohérence européenne pour
pouvoir mieux défendre notre filière
française
si indispensable que ça cet accord avec
le mercosur au final est ce qu'il ya une
vocation absolue à le signer et ce que
vous mettez des lignes rouges je vous
dis aujourd'hui si par exemple sur le
contrôle on n'a pas de garantie on ne
signe pas mais vous savez le président
de la république il a été clair il a
posé des lignes rouges et qui sont et
qui sont les miennes sur le quota bien
évidemment sur les standards de qualité
nous avons posé des conditionnalités sur
les contingents la part de viande
fraîche la part de viande congelée sur
la mise en oeuvre de l'accord dès lors
où il aurait été signé et nous avons
souhaité à ce qu'il puisse y avoir une
clause de sauvegarde qui nous
permettrait si l'accord était signé
et lorsqu'il serait mis en oeuvre c'est
à dire dans plusieurs années de vérifier
si nous avons une chute des prix ou une
baisse de la qualité de faire en sorte
que l'accord ne soit pas mis en eau si
cet accord est signé aujourd'hui il
n'est pas signé et nous savons que les
choses ne sont pas si simples que ça
encore signé tous les cas alors nous
devons continuer à travailler avec la
filière bovine pour faire en sorte que
l'on puisse porter de la qualité aller
sur les marchés export que nous avons
ouvert j'en parlais tout à l'heure des
leurs actes la turquie la chine
nous avons besoin de cela oui justement
j'allais vous ne posez la question si
cet accord est signé le meilleur
souvenir que s'il entre en application
2024 oui 2000 question est qu'est-ce
qu'on va gagner nous en échange
qu'est-ce qu'on va gagner est ce qu'on
va pouvoir exporter plus facilement
qu'elle quel est le gain espéré
bien évidemment nous avons serré aussi
alors le cas d'ailleurs d'un accord
comme ça sur l'industrie automobile par
exemple sur les fromages sur les vins et
spiritueux mais le président de la
république et moi même nous disons
depuis le début que l'agriculture ne
sera pas la variable d'ajustement d'un
accord travail donc je pense que les
choses sont claires bon nous avons
envers milliards à défendre
l'agriculture c'est une des priorités de
ce quinquennat et ne souhaitons la
mettre en oeuvre
jérémy oui oui vous plaidez pour une pac
offensive c'est ce que vous promettez
mais ce que l'union européenne on a les
moyens la grande bretagne s'en va le
grand bassin et des contributeurs nets
au budget de la bac est ce que l'union
européenne aura les moyens de ses
ambitions
alors nous verrons si un certain nombre
d'états membres
certains souhaitent abonder au budget
delà de la pac nous nous avons à
travailler sur notre cadre financier
pluriannuel bien évidemment il faudra
tenir compte du départ du royaume-uni au
niveau de l'europe est de faire en sorte
que avec cette baisse de 5% du budget
c'est à peu près ce qui se passera sur
la pac
regardez comment nous pouvons être
malgré tout très offensif là dessus ce
qui compte c'est que les ambitions de la
pac ne bouge pas ce qui compte c'est que
nous puissions faire en sorte de créer
les conditions où la pac demain elle
sera en mesure de bien protéger nos
agriculteurs nous souhaitons maintenir
je dirais les paiements directs sur le
premier pilier
c'est à dire qu'il n'y ait pas de
cofinancement et quand j'entends la
petite musique qui voudrait dire que
nous souhaitons renationaliser la pac
je dis non nous ne souhaitons pas
renationaliser la pac nous souhaitons
faire en sorte que les paiements directs
s'applique sur le premier pilier
nous nous ne souhaitons même pas que
cette histoire de cofinancement sur le
premier pilier soit une hypothèse de
travail
ce sont aussi nos lignes rockeur et nous
souhaitons créer cette épargne de
précaution comme je disais tout à
l'heure pour les interventions en cas de
jérémy une question complémentaire
une fois les crédits obtenus sur quoi
les flécher vous et est ce que justement
c'est l'occasion de
reprendre ce le modèle agricole français
avec ses crédits alors il faudra les
refondre sur différents différents axes
bien évidemment tout ce qui va concerner
l'innovation pourquoi ne pas fléché
aussi sur des investissements collectifs
je vois que c'est importe c'est
important de pouvoir mutualiser un bon
nombre de par exemple sur la gestion des
effluents
ce sont des investissements qui coûte
très très cher et donc nous avons besoin
de pouvoir mutualiser cela pour
plusieurs exploitations agricoles et
pourquoi cela ne serait pas par les
aides de la pac alors autres dossiers
européens qui sème la révolte dans les
campagnes en tous les cas dans certaines
zones des zones défavorisées qui vont
sortir de la fameuse carte des aides
écoutez votre interpellation monsieur le
ministre par christiane lambert la
présidente de la fnsea
monsieur le ministre vous avez finaliser
la carte des zones défavorisées simples
1349 communes en sont exclus c'est un
vrai casse tête pour les agriculteurs
qui s'interroge sur comment vont-ils
pouvoir faire en perdant cette aide qui
était essentielle pour leur exploitation
qui vous avait annoncé un plan
d'accompagnement en disant vous ne
laisseriez personnes sans solution
est ce que pouvait en dire un petit peu
plus parce que pour l'instant nous ne
voyons pas clair alors voilà
elle ne voit pas clair dit la présidente
de la fnsea madame lambert rencontré il
ya quelques instants par contre un
chalmé et eloïse grégoire que vous lui
répondez vous et bien aujourd'hui
effectivement il ya mille trois cent
quarante neuf communes qui sortent et je
sais que c'est un drame pour les
agriculteurs qui sont dans ces communes
pour autant il ya plus de 5000 communes
qui rentrent mais celle là on ne les
entend pas c'est toujours comme ça en
temps ce qu'est ce soleil ceux qui ne
sont pas content et je les comprends
s'exprime et c'est normal qu'il le fasse
aujourd'hui je les dis nous ne
laisserons personne au bord de la route
mais cette carte qui a été fait c'est la
carte d'aujourd'hui elle date de 1976
j'avais 6 ans lorsqu'elle a été
constitué vous vous rendez compte
et donc cette carte elle avait été bâti
sur des critères qui n'était pas pour le
moins objectifs lorsqu'elle a été fait
aujourd'hui la commission européenne
nous demandent depuis 2003 de refaire
cette carte et aucun gouvernement depuis
le courage de prendre ce dossier en main
et de faire le travail nécessaire c'est
à nous qu'il revient de le faire et
c'est à nous que revient la difficulté
d'aller expliquer aux agriculteurs qui
sortent de ces communes et qui vont
perdre du revenu comment nous allons en
votre réponse d'eads à pédagogie
alors ma réponse ce n'est pas seulement
la pédagogie c'est quoi alors ma réponse
c'est quoi c'est de dire à ces communes
qui vont sortir d'ailleurs d'abord nous
avons encore une marge de négociation
avec la commission européenne un carte
n'est pas figé la carte elle est celle
que nous avons transmises à la
commission européen nous avons un
certain nombre de critères qui ont été
mis livré à la commission européenne sur
lesquels nous demandons à la commission
européenne de nous dire si ces critères
sont fondées ou non et certains par
exemple je pense aux critères de
continuité territoriale pourrait nous
permettre de récupérer quelques communes
donc je pense que nous serons en
diminution je voudrais dire aussi sur le
nombre d'agriculteurs parce que nous
n'avons pas communiqué sur le nombre
d'exploitants nous sommes sur les
chiffres du r ga 2010 donc entre 2010 et
2018 il ya un certain nombre
d'exploitations qui ont disparu donc il
y aura peut-être moins d'exploitants que
prévu qui sortiront du référentiel et
puis qu'est ce que nous allons faire
pour ceux qui sont toujours là et ce
qu'ils vont sortir
nous allons les accompagner nous allons
créer des groupes de groupes de travail
un groupe de travail territoriale avec
les acteurs régionaux les élus et des
groupes de travail sur chaque territoire
destiné à nous occuper de la situation
individuelle d avid d'acteur il sent pas
abandonné ils ne seront pas abandonnés
parce que nous avons besoin de les
accompagner de les aider à transformer
leurs modèles de les aider à travers de
l'investissement de les aider à travers
un certain nombre de mesures sur
lesquelles nous allons travailler avec
eux dès la fermeture de ce salon alors
il ya tellement de professionnels ici
qu'elles se sentent un peu abandonnés
vous le savez
monsieur le ministre il entendait à
longueur de journée on l'a dit en
commençant cette émission et c'est le
cas notamment des éleveurs de certaines
zones de montagne pas seulement
d'ailleurs avec une interrogation autour
du plan loup il ya beaucoup
d'interrogations beaucoup de questions
qu'est ce que vous pouvez dire
aujourd'hui aux éleveurs qui s'inquiète
pour les rassurer
jusqu'où vous êtes prêts à aller
aujourd'hui moi j'ai toujours dit que je
défends des l'agropastoralisme que je
défends des les éleveurs mais qu' il
fallait aussi protéger la biodiversité
et que moi je souhaite que l'on puisse
tendre vers une diminution de la
prédation de la pression de la prédation
et je rappelle qu'aujourd'hui avec le
plan que nous avons mis en place un
éleveur qui est attaquée à la capacité
de se défendre et il a la capacité
oui mais au delà au delà du certains de
quotas qui a été fixé mais il fallait
quand il fallait fixer un quota nous
étions à la fin d'emploi l'heure il
fallait fixer un quota pour pouvoir bien
à l'heure au delà du retard ce dont se
défend toujours ou pas mais bien sûr si
vous êtes attaqués vous des valeurs il
ya plus de quoi au delà du quota vous
pouvez vous défendre
si vous êtes attaqués vous pouvez vous
défendre mais ce que nous souhaitons
aussi s'est décentralisé la décision
pensez vous que cela soit normal
aujourd'hui que ce soit moi dans mon
bureau rue de varenne qui prennent la
décision lorsqu'un agriculteur est
attaqué dans l'aveyron comme j'en ai vu
un certain nombre ou dans les
hautes-alpes ou dans les alpes de haute
provence
nous souhaitons territorialisée ces
dossiers faire en sorte que ce soit le
préfet avec les agriculteurs qui
prennent les bonnes décisions pour ce
qui concerne leur élevage et la nature
de la protection de leurs vaches en tous
les cas on retient que les éleveurs ont
le droit de se dé les branques ans et je
voudrais vous rappeler aussi que
indépendamment du plan loup alors un nom
pas d'aller au-delà du quota au delà du
quota mais que lorsque vous êtes
attaqués vous pouvez vous défendre
je pense que les choses sont claires oui
il ya un quota qui a été mis parce qu'il
fallait fixer un quota
cependant ce que je veux vous dire c'est
que nous sommes avec ce nouveau plan
loup c'est un compromis qui a été bâtie
entre les uns et les autres et qui nous
permet aujourd'hui d'avoir une
visibilité sur 6 mois et dans six mois
nous ferons
un rapport sur je dirais le l'exercice
lors de ses six mois et nous verrons si
nous devons adapter ou modifier un
certain nombre de choses deux dernières
questions pour conclure comment est ce
que le président de la république à
modifier son image ici dans le monde
agricole après sa visite de samedi
dans le mot il est améliorée c'est le
président de la république l'agriculture
je voulais dit tout à l'heure tout ce
que nous avons fait depuis six mois sur
l'agriculture le président il aime la
ruralité
il aime l'agriculture il en a fait une
priorité il était très heureux d'avoir
passé pas loin de 13 heures
ici sur ce salon il me l'a confié à la
sortie nous avions passé tous les deux
une journée une journée pour convaincre
une journée pour expliquer et la russie
faudra qu'il fasse encore mieux l'an
prochain alors il faudrait qu'ils
restent 14h alors ça va ça va nous mener
où ça après y'a plus personne à personne
et au salon ferme ses caractères on peut
ce progrès tout seul dans les allées
mais je vois pas l'intérêt c'est à
travers merci beaucoup merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation ici au salon de
l'agriculture merci à vous merci à tous
et à très vite et merci au public qui
n'a pas oublié avec beaucoup d'attention
et beaucoup de respect pour la parole
ministériel un pas d'émeute pas de
chahut aujourd'hui
le respect
[Musique]